white house press secretary kaley
mcinerney joins us now kaylee good
morning thanks for being with us
why is the president pushing
hydroxychloroquine again
when his own health experts say it's not
effective in treating the virus
so the president believes and has a
positive outlook for this drug
and as a prophylaxis and in the early
stages he looks at
the henry ford study that came out which
was very positive and the henry
ford ceo coming out and saying that this
could save lives a yale epidemiologist
said that much this week as well but the
president's always been clear that this
drug which has been approved for 65
years
and has a good safety profile should
only be used in the context of a
prescription from your doctor he wants
to save lives
that is his goal here and that's why
he's promoting this drug as a
prophylaxis but only in consultation
with your doctor
yeah i should point out dr fauci said uh
the overwhelming medical evidence is
that it's not effective
i wanted to ask about the the retweet
the president made which uh which
jericho just referred to
uh about a doctor saying people do not
need to wear masks shutdowns
are unnecessary this just comes a week
after the president said masks are
patriotic
there's a shift in tone here and what
appear to be very mixed messages why
so that was a three second remark in a
more than five minute video the
overall purpose of that video was for
the president to
illustrate his views on
hydroxychloroquine in part he agreed
with
those lines from the video but in terms
of wearing a mask that very day
he himself wore a mask i was with him
when he did that he's been very clear
that wearing a mask
is patriotic so that was not the intent
and tweeting out that specific video
that was a small portion but you there's
a message in there that suggests
it's not necessary and the pr it comes
from the president who has 80 million
followers did he not look at the whole
video
the president did look at the whole
video and the overarching message of the
video more than five minutes from this
doctor was talking about
hydroxychloroquine he wore a mask that
day
nothing could be more illustrative to
his followers that masks are important
than him
he himself wearing a mask when he
couldn't socially distance as he did
that very day when we went to north
carolina as you heard a new cbs
news poll shows that a majority of
americans 57 percent
uh believe the president is is doing a
bad job
handling the outbreak is there any shift
in strategy
possible here in terms of dealing with
the coronavirus
we're still hard at work the way we
always have been we believe that the
american people recognize um how
much this president has done in this
covid pandemic look we've had around
severe and convalescent plasma and all
of these encouraging therapeutics like
steroids that are only made possible
because of the president tearing down
bureaucratic
tape you have a vaccine that's in phase
three clinical trial moderna
13 other vaccines as well we learned
pfizer went to phase two and three late
stage human
trials all of this is made possible by
this president he's hard at work and we
believe ultimately the american people
recognize that
the senate has a relief plan on the
table they're negotiating with the
democrats the president has said
he doesn't like some parts of that plan
what does he not like
so i'll leave it to him to parse out
exactly what he doesn't like about that
plan
i would imagine a lot of it has to do
with the payroll tax holiday which would
have been a huge tax break
for low and middle income americans the
president fought hard for that and that
did not make it in
but what did make it in are unemployment
benefits being extended which the
president said is a huge priority to him
direct payments uh to americans and
money for our schools reopening this is
those parts of the plan are very good we
wish the payroll tax holiday would have
made its way in
but these unemployment benefits being
extended is paramount in the president's
mind
the bill includes nearly 1.8 billion
dollars for a new
fbi headquarters with senator mcconnell
it seemed to surprise him when it was
mentioned to him and he said talk to the
white house about it why is it in there
so this was um part of the president's
priority of updating the fbi building
keeping it
in d.c and it's been one of the things
that's been mentioned it's in this bill
and it's
a part of one of the president's
priorities and it's been a priority for
several months yeah but what's it doing
in a coronavirus bill
well it's in the bill um the president's
made clear that this is what he wants to
see it's not a
a deal breaker what the priority here is
unemployment benefits as the president
said and that is the the ultimate
priority
um so the fbi part is one portion a
small portion of what is an overarching
bill
on covid and the priority as he said
yesterday is those unemployment benefits
you've said it's safe for schools to
reopen but we're hearing from teachers
about the possibility of striking some
are even talking about making wills
what do you say to teachers who don't
want to go back to school
until the situation is clearer well the
president has said that vulnerable
teachers
should stay home those with
comorbidities but we can open school
safely because we believe just like the
media
our essential workers just like our meat
packers that teachers are too it's
really important we know that one in
five child abuse cases are reported in
schools
that kids depend on getting nutrition in
schools and it's very important for
single working moms and dads out there
that they have the opportunity to put
their child in school get them educated
and they don't fall behind because we
know that that disproportionately
affects low income students in
particular who fall behind
the most when they don't have access to
school kaylee mcinerney thank you very
much for being with us this morning
thank you very
much